I'm the mom who went before my school
board last September in Fairfax County
to expose the pornography in my son's
high school in Fairfax
[Applause]
possible that we have reached a point
where a human solution is no longer
viable I am reaching a point where I
don't see a human solution as a way out
of this mess that we're in I don't think
we have to choose right I agree with you
that there isn't a human solution in
that this isn't something we can do on
our own none of us are equipped to do
this on our own is that we're all made
to feel like we are alone and we're not
but you couldn't do that if it was just
you right without God working through
you I do think we need a divine
intervention but what we find so often
in human history is that God works
through people he's working through us
right now you know I talked about the
advantages that we have and I focused a
lot on just how weak and flimsy gender
ideology is but I I shouldn't I should
not have neglected to mention that the
other big Advantage we have is that we
have God on our side